candidates are making their final
pitches to voters ahead of turkey as
presidential and parliamentary elections
the incumbent erdogan is facing an
opposition Alliance led by Kamal
khalidsteroglu in an extremely tight
race
who's joining us now live from the
National Alliance opposition rally in
Ankara Hashem over to you
Darin as the campaign gets into the
final stage this is one of the last
rallies by the opposition Coalition
which is the nation Alliance and joining
me to talk about the environment what's
happening and the promises made in the
past by the oppositions Mr Alibaba who
was former foreign minister former
deputy prime minister in 2020
established which is the democracy and
progress party you're part of the
opposition coalition
less than 48 hours before the vote
what are your chances well greetings
from Ankara my hometown this is the last
reality of our coalition
and we are moving towards elections of
Sunday
which will be a big win and big victory
for democracy because we are
pro-democracy and we will win it the
presidential candidates said that if he
wins the election there's going to be a
reset of foreign policy they will
reverse the decisions made in the past
by President
particularly when it comes to the US and
the EU you were a former top negotiator
with the EU what does that mean
well it means
consistency in foreign policy it means
foreign policy based on Mutual national
interests it means foreign policy based
on common values like Humanity like
fundamental rights and freedoms turkey
is a part of NATO we are allies in
nature we are also an accession country
to the European Union so these are very
important groupings are you getting any
guarantees that if you get elected you
will resume talks with you about joining
them of course our Target will be EU
standards High economic and political
standards of the EU that is our very
clear Target
and being a member of the EU depends on
Mutual political decision which could be
a long way away from now which could
definitely take some time let me ask you
a question but at the same time there
are concerns or at least it was
interpreted that that reset of the
following policy means you want to have
very good times with Vladimir Putin of
Russia
turkey is a country in the Balkans
turkey is a country in the Caucasus
turkey is a country in the Middle East
so we are going to have very good
relations with a with a very large
geography our relations will be based on
common interests meaning political and
economic interests and we believe in
a cooperation cooperation is going to be
a key word of course turkey is a
Sovereign Nation of course turkey is
going to be very sensitive about its
national interests but that does not
include that does not exclude having
good relations with wide variety of
countries including Russia of course
particularly when it comes to neighbor
when it comes to the Middle East the art
party has been known for redefining in a
way or another very strong relations
when it comes to the Middle East and
people in the Middle East are pretty
much concerns that are win by the
opposite of the opposition means that
those relations will be strange in the
future that's nonsense because what
binds us with the Middle East is culture
is history and it can never change
so what is going to happen is we are
going to make it very easy for people to
move between countries we will make it
easy for goods to move easily and also
financing Capital so Fremont of capital
free moment of people free moment of uh
also ideas is going to be very important
so it means good relations and better
relations but it also means consistency
so the Foreign Relations of turkey is
not going to be dependent on the mood of
one person it is going to be based on
rationality and consistency thank you
very much indeed Mr Alibaba chandarin as
you can see both candidates from both
different camps are offering different
Visions about how to move forward when
it comes to Turkey particularly when it
comes to foreign policy these are
exciting moments extraordinary moments
here in Turkey this could perhaps be one
of the tightest races ever in modern
history of turkey and this explains that
perhaps the one who's going to be able
to win the hearts and minds of the Swing
voters the new 5 million young voters
who are going to cast their votes for
the first time in these elections Could
Be the One to win the election back to
you Doreen thank you so much reporting
for us from Ankara